pour poursuivre avec ces mesures
militaires dont on vient de parler prise
par monsieur carter il s'agit donc
essentiellement de renforcer cette base
de guantanamo située sur l'île même de
cuba et dont on avait un peu oublié
l'existence et d'autre part donc de
faire manoeuvrer la flotte américaine
dans la mer des caraïbes
serge me seraient les premières unités
de la deuxième flotte américaine
viennent d'arriver dans la mer des
caraïbes en tout 16 bâtiments qui vont
manoeuvrer pendant 12 jours au large de
cuba mais aussi dans toute la région où
leur présence sera interprété du - jimmy
carter l'espère-t-il comme un
durcissement de l'attitude américaine
ces bâtiments relâcheront probablement à
guantanamo base américaine sur le sol
cuba une ville un port des champs de
broussailles et des mines
quarante kilomètres carrés de superficie
il y à la 6000 américains environ 3000
soldats et leurs familles
les états unis vont envoyer 15 cents
soldats de plus guantanamo est
certainement la plus vieille bases
américaines à l'étranger cédé à
perpétuité par le gouvernement cubain en
1903 inutile de dire que fidel castro a
maintes fois invité ses hôtes à partir
mais les américains se sont incrustés et
maintenant jimmy carter vient d'ordonner
le renforcement de la surveillance de
cuba il ya quelques mois les militaires
américains voulaient abandonner
guantanamo la base n'ayant plus il est
il un grand intérêt stratégique